at today's echofon council had an
important debate on the way forward that
should be taken on to that proposals
that we have on the table the reduced
VAT rate on electronically supplied
publications and the general reverse
charge mechanism regarding the g20 the
presidency the Commission and also the
g20 host country Germany informed the
Council of the results of the g20
meeting main controversy was the
international trade which attracted much
attention since it was the first meeting
with the participation of the new US
administration and the final communique
language on trade was as we all know we
could then would have desired climate
related issue also was problematic
nevertheless to work the in the area
would go on our main messages that
economic growth in Europe continues and
our economic policy mix investment
structural reforms and responsible
fiscal policies is working on financial
sector we inform some ministers on the
public consultation that we launched
today on the operation of European
supervisory authorities these Europeans
are provided authorities played a key
role in ensuring the financial markets
across the you Arbor regulated stay
strong and stable